alright next video here The Grateful
Dead all right let's let's play I'm not
deciding not side yeah there we go I let
that be a groove out I have no idea
about this happening but I haven't
played it so often on video so I hope I
get something which I at least know a
bit ok take cm castles now a 6 is the
main line but hmm it's not like I'm an
expert ok try to try some other stuff 96
is also possibility and then if I if I
saw this idea in a book recently normal
move I think it's Bishop g4
the idea of this move is that on d5 I go
nite deform right in the middle and get
some hopefully favorable complications
and are quite sure how i discontinued
after that but at least he spent some
time he takes a five I can just play on
Nyjah for and get this pound back with a
pretty good position i think would gain
your temp on the Queen alcohol right I
think night in you five okay okay could
have just taken you to and now I'm i
think rupee aids or was it c6
c6
66 was correct okay now threatening 95 I
think what needs to go d6 here more or
less needs to not question I don't think
as any other move so d6 and what then
rook e8 then e 5 maybe yeah maybe this
is possible
yeah of course it's better if you if you
really know the line what is spending a
lot of time as well this is somewhat
reassuring that it won't be a tutor or
at least half a time the time advantage
okay but I don't I'd not quite sure what
you're thinking about I think t6 is very
very naturally ok sorry ok what is what
about this move I could take d5 bay
rookie aid it's quite quite some
possibilities here
ok let's go to create first attacking
you form it takes on ok so he wants to
return the pawn ok ok let's let's take
it at least I have a powerful g7 Bishop
now right ok questions Queen takes do
you want can you play rub text you want
maybe you can yeah most likely you can
rookie to look the at Bishop FN Bishop
age six and i'm most likely in a bad way
huh ok but
roop deform maybe to gain a temple ok
don't I want to spend so much time it's
not exactly a dream square for the rook
blocking the bishop and allowing we
should be three somehow it looks looks
wrong no idea ok but it's not like that
is I got any super great move now yeah
okay I don't mind Midas pawn getting
lost how to continue
yet clear that I have some compensation
but it's not so clear cut out to
continue we've got very nice bishops
here and by the rookie sound on a
strange square but it's not not passive
so
yeah this should be 3 move for some miss
annoying really
if I move this rock group do you want
also it's not very comfortable maybe
trying to get rid of the Queen here so
yeah this will get decided with very low
time on the clock at some difficult
Bishop e3 I always have this route
before move this should wouldn't be to
back quickly so it's it's it's not
really like I'm not a point down for for
nothing but somehow it feels like I
played it wrong
no but it's very slow really
what is he doing
okay white resides all right yeah well
he will overstep the time if he was even
slower than me spending five minutes on
22 moves yeah I think I had some
compensation for the pawn but yeah maybe
maybe I played this wrong here this
route de force is just a move that you
don't want to play yeah computer also
wants to play this yeah it's not bad for
black and but it's it feels very
unnatural to put the rocker on the under
stay again or jump work T phone takes
Bishop takes computer place exactly the
same now he wants to play rook before I
of course this is also possible yeah
here gives white its large voltage yeah
difficult I had some some computation
but it was difficult to play yeah thanks
for watching